foreign
georgia
georgia
just an old sweet song
keeps georgia on my mind
georgios
is through the plans
other arms reach out to me
other i
smile
tenderly
still in the peaceful dreams i see
the road
leads back to you
i said georgia
just an old sweet song
keeps georgia
on my mind
you go in the middle peter
okay
welcome
in this
family friends and admirers like
myself
have just celebrated
the first 90 years
of the extraordinary life
of our distinguished guest
i am ernesto cedillo ponce de leon
of the center for the study of
globalization
my colleagues and i
are extremely proud
that this great man
from
georgia has accepted our invitation to
come to our university today
from its inception
our center was committed
to engage
not only in the study of economic
globalization
but also
with the essential questions of
governance
human rights rule of law
and peace and security in our global
village
on these matters
there is no better way to inspire the
necessary good ideas
and the right actions
than to have with us
people who with great distinction
have dedicated their lives to those
noble causes
we have had the privilege of welcoming
many great women and men in that
category
not least three nobel peace lorets
kofi annan marti attisahari
and mohammed el varade
today we welcome another novel lord
a man considered universally
a champion of democracy
a tireless defender of human rights for
all
and
with a special courage and lucidity
those rights of women and girls
as you will attest today
he is also a passionate advocate for
development and the alleviation of
poverty
and of course a promoter
and a remarkable achiever of
international peace
this
outstanding man who i insist is an
inspiration to people in all corners of
the planet
happens to be the 39th president of the
united states of america
i respectfully ask our president peter
salovey to introduce him
thank you
thank you ernesto appreciate that good
night
thank you president zadia
welcome everyone
delighted that so many of you have
joined us here today for a very special
occasion
i'm humbled by the opportunity to
introduce to the stage
and to yell
a man
whose contributions to democracy and
human rights
across the country and around the world
are unparalleled
the 39th president of the united states
and recipient of the nobel peace prize
james earl carter jr affectionately
known to countless citizens around the
world as
jimmy carter
during his presidency and in the decades
since
president carter has been a champion
for so many of the core values that are
central to our community here at yale
he has embraced causes and led efforts
that in the simplest terms
make the world a better place
as president he led the country toward
energy security and civil service reform
expanded the national park system
and created the department of education
since then
he has worked with habitat for humanity
promoted health care in africa and latin
america
contributed to peace building in the
middle east
and monitored elections and fledgling
democracies
through his own personal efforts and
through the work of the carter center
which he and his wife rosalind founded
more than three decades ago he is a
remarkable supporter
of human rights
health
peace
democracy and freedom
across the globe
twelve years ago he was awarded the
nobel peace prize reflecting to quote
the prize citation
his decades of untiring effort
to find peaceful solutions to
international conflicts
to advance democracy and human rights
and to promote economic
and social development
moreover he has carried out this work
with deep integrity and humility
a quiet but unflagging commitment
to improving the lives of all of the
world's citizens
he exemplifies the qualities and values
that we at gale
hope to instill in the future leaders
we are educating here on campus
president carter is not just a
distinguished practitioner practitioner
but also a scholar a scholar of global
affairs
since 1975 he has authored 28 books
his latest work a call to action
women religion violence and power
focuses on what president carter calls
the most serious and unaddressed
worldwide challenge of our time
the discrimination and abuse
of women and girls
this groundbreaking book reflects his
wisdom and perspective
as a firsthand witness
to a system of discrimination that
extends to every nation in which women
are routinely deprived of education
health care and equal opportunity
forced to suffer servitude in child
marriage
or trapped along with their children
in cycles of poverty war and violence
this important work not only examines
the most shocking and disturbing human
right abu human rights abuses abroad but
also covers many timely issues that
affect women and girls here in the
united states
such as sexual assault
and discrimination that results in fewer
promotions lower pay
and unequal representation in leadership
positions in politics and other sectors
of society
the book also contains a thoughtful
exploration of the deeply ingrained and
incorrect interpretations of many
religious texts
which are contorted to suggest that men
are superior to women
and which are often used to justify the
subjugation and abuse
of women and girls
we are tremendously grateful to
president carter
for joining us to discuss his book
and the worldwide challenges of our time
following his remarks ernesto zadillo
and i
will moderate a discussion using
questions that you all have submitted
to us
it is now my profound honor
to introduce
the 39th president of the united states
jimmy carter
thank you
thank you
thank you very much
well first of all let me say that i'm
very grateful for the words that i just
heard from peter and ernesto
and i'm also glad to be back at yale
i told the president at lunch that i had
spent one weekend here when i was
governor of georgia back in 1974
and i was planning to run for president
and i came here to get some attention
i was more of southern curiosity at that
time
and but now that i have been president i
really appreciate these much more
exemplary comments about me a lot of a
lot of people ask me how does it feel to
be a former president
uh and i tell them that one one thing
that illustrates this is best i know is
a cartoon that was in a new york or
magazine a couple years ago this little
boy looks up at his father he says daddy
when i grow up i want to be a former
president
so there's a lot of good things about it
i really realized how nice that was when
i left the white house and i went to
china where i had normalized diplomatic
relations with with that country on the
way back my wife and i stopped
in japan
and i made a speech to a little small
college at graduation time in southern
uh japan in osaka as a matter of fact
uh when i was on the stage getting ready
to prepare my speech i saw that
everybody was really uptight the
students were nervous their parents were
nervous the professors were nervous
and uh
i just left the white house there's a
reason and so i made my speech but i
decided to start it off with a joke
and it takes a long time to say
something in english in japanese
so i decided i wouldn't tell my funniest
joke i just tell my shortest joke
so i told my joke and everybody
collapsed and laughed it's the best
results i've ever had from a joke in my
life and i couldn't wait to get my
speech through so i could go back in the
green room and ask the interpreter how
did you tell my joke
and uh he was very evasive
um
but i insisted and finally the
interpreter looked the other way and he
said we kind of mumble i told the
audience president carter told a funny
story everyone must laugh
so you see there are some advantages to
being a former president
well one of those advantages is to look
back on a life i'm now 90 years old and
uh i have been
able to learn some things in my life i
started out as a boy
on a farm about two and a half miles
west of plains georgia plains has now
grown we are now have 630 people in our
town
uh but at that time it was a big city
for me but all of my neighbors
on the farm were african-americans i
didn't have any white neighbors
and i grew up in a society
in the south and also in the north
that was committed and enjoying the
white people were the privileges of
separate but equal
which was the law of the land in our
country for a hundred years
from the 1860s at the end of the civil
war to the 1960s
and people who were
white and i would say quite liberal
went along with this
economic and political
benefit
silently
because the white folks didn't want to
change
their privilege status
and the same thing is taking place now
around the world including in this
country
in the derogation
or subjugation
of women and girls
the carter center
which my wife and i had
have has had programs in 88 countries on
earth my wife and i have visited more
than 145 nations
and during the last 30 years i've been
able to look at what happens in those
countries
to see some of the horrible examples of
the depravation of equal rights
of girls
if a family has
a couple of children
and they're stricken with poverty
the boy
gets the best food
the girl
is the one that goes to school
and in later life the girl is restricted
in her evolution or
development of god's given rights
and talents
compared to the boy
this has permeated our society
and the reasons for it are quite
comprehensible but somewhat
complex
i mentioned in the title of my book
women
religion
violence and power
a lot of the great religions now
teach their followers their believers
that women are inferior in the eyes of
god
my wife and i
were
very devout southern baptist i was for
70 years
and in the year 2000 the southern
baptist convention in orlando florida
ordained
that women
had to be subject
to their husbands
and that women could no longer be
pastors of a church or deacons
or chaplains and that in
a southern baptist seminary a woman
could not teach a class
if there was a boy among the students
my wife and i withdrew from the southern
baptist convention
and we now belong to a small church in
plains that had women pastors my wife
has been a deacon
and we have equality in our church
between men and women but that is a
symbol of what goes on in many great
religions on earth
as you know the catholic church which i
admire very much
has had a policy since the second or
third century at least
that a woman cannot be
a pastor a priest and a woman cannot be
a deacon
a woman cannot
observe the ordinance
audiences that are important to the
catholic church i'm not criticizing the
catholic church but to point out to you
that this is pervasive
and if a an employer wants to hire
men and women in his in his business
knowing that god looks upon women as
inferior
he feels much less guilt if he pays men
more
than women
in some countries on earth the abuse is
quite
severe
i have had a lot to do with egypt i
negotiated a peace agreement between
egypt and israel and we have been in
egypt ever since until just
recently egypt has a law against genital
cutting or mutilation
but 91 percent of all the females in
egypt today
have had their genitals mutilated
by a woman who's known as a cutter
who has a razor blade or a sharp knife
and she removes all the exterior
portions
of a woman's sexual organs quite often a
little girl before they're four years
old and in some cases she sews up the
orifice
so that a woman a girl can only urinate
or administrate
when she gets married
they
cut the harvest back open
so she can have sex and bear children
in djibouti and somalia and other
countries i can name 97
of all the females
have had this done to them
and in about 30 percent of all african
countries more than 50 percent of the
women
have suffered this
abuse
it's not well known
but it takes place
and it requires education and so forth
support to be corrected in my book i
spell out how it can be corrected
we all have seen stories of
i would say the abuse of girls
who have been sexually assaulted
by a stranger
if a girl has been raped
in a many families both christian and
islamic and others
she's looked upon as a disgrace to the
family
and she is
executed
by her parents
75 percent by men 20 percent by women
and increasingly by a young brother
because they
if it's against the law which it is in
most countries won't be punished because
they're juveniles
honor killings is called
that's not the worst of it
there are
horrible events that have taken place in
our history
the most costly war that we know about
was the second world war
a few more than 40 million people died
in the world during the second world war
40 million
at this moment
there are 160 million
girls missing from the face of the earth
because they have been
strangled
by their parents at birth
or now with the advent of sonograms
which can be just plugged into
an ipad
they can be detected as females when
they're still a fetus
and they are aborted before birth
in china today for every 100 girls
living
there are 118 boys
in india the second largest country on
earth
for every hundred girls they're 112 boys
and in many countries where the
governments don't ordain a small family
if the family is very poor they just
get rid of the girls when they're born
there's a movie that came out a year ago
last month called it's a girl maybe some
of you have seen it
there's one
woman from india there who very brazenly
and somewhat proudly says that she
strangled eight daughters
when they were born
because her husband and she could not
afford
to feed them
that's foreign countries most of that
but we have a horrible situation in this
country as well
and the reason it has persisted and
still is growing
is because we don't want to admit
that it goes on
partially because we are responsible
the two i would say most revered or
respected institutions
in america are the great universities
and the military
the
recent news reports of
sexual assault on campuses has been
quite revealing
it's been
gross
and embarrassing for many generations
with the advent of more and more girls
students so
i would say the incidence has probably
grown in recent years
every
university has this problem
i've been a college professor at emory
university now this is my 33rd year
it happens at emory happens at yale
at harvard
recently we've seen a story about
university of virginia another great
university
the rapes happened
two years ago in 2012
they were covered up
by the college administrators
until
rolling stone had an article about it
and then slowly but surely
the university started correcting the
problem
one out of ten girls who enter an
american university will be raped
before she graduates
one out of five
will be sexually assaulted that is
approached
in a suggestive sexual way without her
permission
but most university administrators
deans presidents and others don't want
it to be known
that on their campuses these things take
place and when it comes to a choice
between uh
effective football player
and a freshman girl
the football player is more valuable to
keep on the copy college campus
ninety percent of all the rapes
on american university campuses
as reported by the department of justice
last month
ninety percent
are perpetrated by four percent
of his students
because when a boy who has that
inclination gets to be a college
student they know that they can rape
someone
with impunity
in civilian life about 33 percent of all
the rapes are reported
to the authorities on college campuses
in america less than five percent
because the girls on the college
campuses are discouraged
one way or the other from making a
report
well
the same thing takes in its place in the
military i was in the navy for 12 years
i was a submarine officer
and i know that a commanding officer
does not want to admit to his superiors
or her superiors
that crimes take place under their
command
and that is the law in america now
if you are the commanding officer of a
ship that has females on it
or if you are the commander of a
american
marine battalion or an army
company
by law the
commanding officer has a right to decide
if a reported rape will be
taken to the
stage of trial and punishment
the department of
defense has passed
september excuse me this past may
announced that in 2012 there were 26 000
cases
of sexual assault
reported in the military
26 000 310 of them
found some punishment for the rapist
that's just a little more than one
percent
because the commanding officers do not
want to admit
that the crimes take place
under their
supervision
for full-time employees in america
working a whole year at a time
women make 23 percent less
than men
of course religion is just one of the
factors that causes this
another is violence
where
the abuse of another human being
is an accepted part of our
attitude or philosophy or commitment
when rose and i travel around the world
it's
almost unanimous belief that the most
warlike country on earth is the united
states of america
we've been at war almost constantly
since the second world war
when the united nations was founded to
prevent
further wars
except for four years i won't say which
four years
we've been
we've been at war
with about 30 different countries
and
when i left
office as president
about one out of a thousand americans
were in prison
now
seven out of a thousand are in prison
more than six times as many people are
in american prisons now
as they were
30 something years ago
the increase in the number of black
women in prison is 800 percent
we're the only
developed nation on earth
that has a death penalty
we and china and
iran and saudi arabia
perpetrate 90 of all the world's
executions
slavery
has been
a
crime
in which america was proudly
involved in its abolition
we suffered through
a war that cost six hundred thousand
lives
slavery
now
exceeds
the level of slavery in the 18th or 19th
century there are more people sold
across international borders
involuntarily now
into servitude
than there were in any of those two
centuries
eighty percent of them according to the
united nations
are females
sold into sexual slavery when they
arrived
in a country not their own
in atlanta georgia we had
sessions on this for the last four years
the subject that i'm talking about
in atlanta georgia the official reported
to us that between 200 and 250 people
every month
are sold into slavery
the reason for that atlanta is the
number one
entry point for slaves in this country
the reason for that is atlanta has a
busiest airport by far in the world
and a lot of the passengers that come
into atlanta
are from the southern hemisphere
where their skins
are brown or black
and a brothel owner can buy
a dart-skinned girl
for a thousand dollars
and the average
earnings from that girl per year is
about 35 000
dollars
these
facts
are hard to believe
but they
should be
ever present in your mind
i analyze these very thoroughly and and
i point out where the data come from
they're very static accurate statistics
and at the last
chapter i list 23 things
that every
citizen and every organization can do
to protect women and girls in an equal
way
why should there be
18 of a
population of china
killed
why should women have their sexual
organs
mutilated
why should a girl be
sexually assaulted
on an american university campus
with the
perpetrators
not ever punished
i don't know about yale i haven't looked
at i've seen some articles about yale
earlier
where
those who were
convicted or confessed to sexual assault
stayed on the campus i don't know about
now maybe they are now being dispelled
they are the ones who
do these crimes on college campuses are
serial rapists
why would anybody want
a serial rapist to stay on the campus
but we do
of all the universities in america
41 of them
have not reported a single case of
sexual assault for the last five years
well
let me close by saying that
this is a
challenge for all of us
i would say similar to what slavery was
in olden times
or racial discrimination
under so-called sexual but
as separate but equal rules of the
supreme court 400 years
this is a problem for us to face
the question is do we have the courage
to do it
do we
men want to give up
the special privileges that we have of
having the most tenured professors and
the most presence of colleges and and
the most chief executive officers and
the highest salaries and
so forth
of the fortune 500
corporations
23 of them
out of 500
have women chief executive officers
and they um paid less
on the average than the men
we're making some progress
when i was elected president we had
three percent of a
members of congress u.s congress
who were women
we've now
grown to 15
that's a great progress
the world average is 23
the united states i believe ranked 78th
in the percentage of women who
hold public office at the local state
or national level
it's not my
religion that believes that women are
inferior
i teach
bible lessons every sunday
in my little church
and
the last few years i've studied this
issue quite thoroughly i have a chapter
three in my book is about it
and i
there's no way
that anybody can find one single verse
in the bible that
indicates that jesus christ for instance
ever treated a woman as inferior
in most cases jesus exalted women
my number one ally in trying to deal
with this issue worldwide
is the grand imam of al-azhar
in egypt
that's a university with 120 000
students
but the grand imam is also the spiritual
leader of the sunni muslims
and he points out quite clearly in some
of his public statements and papers
that is nothing in the islamic faith
that derogates a woman
i don't believe there's anything in
the christian faith that derogates
a woman
except as it's interpreted by men
who want to stay ascendant
and superior
and privileged
it's not
a an attractive
subject but it's one that i think is
very important
thank you thank you for that challenge
okay
i have picked the questions you can
put together these are you can make one
question out of these two okay and i
will be
okay and you'll make the you want to
start
one of two
or do you want me to start
yeah why don't you don't complete it
thank you uh
so much president carter for that uh
challenge
the challenge uh that resonates here at
this university and we appreciate uh
that you uh
are uh bringing an awareness to the
world really of um
something that we should uh be ashamed
that we have allowed to let happen for
so long
we have um
questions that you all submitted
and i thought that
ernesto and i would simply um
alternate
in
our asking
president carter them and so why don't
we start with uh
president zadina well actually mr
president i sorted the questions so you
should ask the question so i will do the
first and then you do the rest
well he has always given me orders now
this is my chance to
you know
okay first question which is really
three questions president while
religious conviction can often instigate
and perpetuate oppression of women
could it also be a dynamic force for
affirming their value and dignity
what does your personal faith hold
for women
in the world
and a student of the divinity school
says
as a public figure who has spoken
publicly about your faith
faith how do you feel religious and
political leaders
can work together to achieve social
justice while maintaining appropriate
separation of church
and state
well i think almost everyone who
hosts political office
around the world has some religious
faith that they
admit or sometimes brag about so it's
not a complete separation of church of
state it's just a matter of when you are
in public office don't specify any
particular religion even your own as
being superior
but i think every person in a matter in
a position of authority or influence
even a private citizen who has influence
among a few people
has an obligation to speak out on issues
that are troubling to
him or her and this includes both men
and women
so
as i said earlier the religious faith
that i have
is my own interpretation of the
scriptures they're about 33 000
verses in the holy bible in the old
testament the hebrew text and the uh in
the christian text the new testament and
and you can
very easily
hand pick a particular verse to prove
that you're right
i mentioned the early days that when i
was in plains during the uh
racial segregation days we had biblical
scholars who came to our first baptist
church in plains
to give us proof from the bible
that god ordained that white people
should be superior to blacks
there are some verses that say you know
that slave slavery is is okay
and so we can prove whatever we want to
but i think that that this just has to
be an awakening
of common ordinary people including
leaders as well that this is a problem
that blights
the uh the world
and you can go by how well women are
treated and quite often it shows how the
economic
development of that country has been
progressing
uh if you deprive 50 of your total
population
of a chance to use their brains and
their intelligence and their hard work
and so forth from economic development
you have committed partial economic
suicide so it's a matter of
self-preservation and self-benefit
to do away with this affliction on all
of society
and and what i've tried to point out in
in my book is that it's not necessary
most of the
reasons that parents give me
when i say why do you persecute your
girls they say well we need we don't
have social security
and we want somebody to take care of us
in our old age
i'm convinced that daughters will take
better care of their parents in their
old age than sons will if you give
adults a chance to be educated and get a
job
what about the separation between the
estate
and the church and
do you recognize that well the laws are
passed by people who are in political
affairs like you were president i was
president and and um i think that to
correct societies
to correct societal afflictions you've
got to take action even if it's a moral
issue
for instance we have just recently seen
the
uh
the department of education which is
peter wanted out i created when i was
president
used uh
title ix
which was designed originally to give
women equal rights to sports activities
on college campuses that particular
few paragraphs has now been interpreted
to mean
that the department of education has the
right and duty
to make sure that every university in
america has a corrective action taken to
prevent women from being raped on the
campus so that's a matter of politicians
passing the law and interpreting the law
but
i think it has a great moral benefit
if it when and if it's put into effect
this is a follow-up question in a way on
the uh
the
issue of religion
and this student writes
so how would you actually going about go
about
eliminating
violence against women as practiced
by certain uh interpretations of rel of
certain religions
when the claim is this is just our
tradition this is just part of tradition
how would you actually
uh impact practice
well it's the same thing because we had
a very strong tradition in our country
in some states at least of slavery
uh it was all tradition
and for as i mentioned earlier i think
maybe twice for a hundred years after
the civil war we had a tradition
that was enforced by all of our legal
authorities that uh
it would be separate but equal between
white and black people
it was separate but it certainly was not
equal
and so i think the same thing applies
nowadays in in this respect
religion
i know about the
catholic church policy with which i
disagree
but i'm but i'm not criticizing
and i wrote pope francis a letter about
this book i sent him a copy of the book
as i did every head of state in the
world i sent 193
free books
to
to to every head of government in a
world including pope francis anyway i
got a very nice letter from him return
and he said that he uh he didn't go into
details about it but he said his
prediction was
and his his belief was that women should
play a much greater role in the catholic
church in future years so you know it's
up to him and the catholic authorities
what they do
uh
and and you know the methodist church
and the episcopal church and many others
i need not mention now but not only
having women pastors but also having
women bishops and so forth so it's it's
a it's a changing world and i think
eventually it'll change throughout the
religious
hierarchy in all religions
so this is a student writing with a
question about practical advice says mr
president what practical advice
would you give to students
who want to organize around racial or
economic
or
sexual inequality
should uh students lead a movement what
steps should they take
well i know on emory campus which has
been one of those i think along with
yale and harvard that's been identified
by the department of education as being
a problem
they have now gotten their all of their
fraternities to take the leadership role
in in uh pledging
that they will not any longer have any
sexual abuse within the within the
fraternities themselves there was a case
on the emory campus just a few months
ago
where a girl was abused
and i think that this is a
responsibility for students to demand
that the leadership cooperate with them
and making sure that this is this has
ended one thing to do is not support the
boys who are guilty of sexual assaults
because as i said these are really
serial
rapists on the campus it's just a tiny
number of the of the boys in america in
universities that rape girls but they
know they can get away with on the
college campuses and and they become
serial rapists
so this is something that can be done at
emory there also has been an
organization of of young people who
volunteer if you are a boy for instance
a voice a male student you volunteer to
pledge that if you know about a sexual
assault that you will not conceal it
from authorities so that's the kind of
thing and another thing is for the
university officials
who are in charge of this to to give
education to to girls students when they
come in as freshmen
and and also to give uh education to all
the students in there this is what you
do in case you know about rape but a lot
of students don't know about it and a
lot of girls are really dissuaded from
doing so
and a high percentage of rapes on
college campuses this is also included
in my book
athletes because they're the most
popular and they're the least likely to
be to be expelled
there was a very bad case
in 2012
at the naval academy where i was a
midshipman there
we have now about 20 percent female
midshipmen and a young midshipman
freshman we call plebes was raped by
three football players and it was uh
well known she didn't make any report
but then she began to be teased by her
fellow classmates of having been raped
because the football players were
bragging about the fact that they took
advantage of her and so she finally went
public with it but the problem was that
the superintendent of the naval academy
had unilateral
sole authority to say whether or not the
voice would be prosecuted so so it goes
on in all the universities but i think
the main thing is to let the students
know what's going on and and teach them
if they want to know
what can be done in case there is a case
of sexual assault that they want to
address yeah i think uh our experience
on this campus where we're working hard
on this issue
has been uh
that that
whether we're talking about prevention
and education whether we're talking
about adjudication whether we're talking
about punishment
when we've worked with our students
directly and collaboratively our
students who are
most passionate about this issue
who are
most knowledgeable about this issue i
think we've come to the best that's good
i read i read one article on the way up
here on the plane as a matter of fact
from huffington post they pointed out
that yale had i think in previous years
six uh people only stood
six boys that had been found
guilty or admitted that they had
committed sexual assault and they had
not been expelled
you know it's very
you know you can just warn a boy and
chastise him
that doesn't help but the expulsion is a
very difficult thing for our university
to to accept as a policy
i think
i think our policies and procedures have
changed over the last year or two
i'm not surprised
see different outcomes
um on a different issue
there's a i've got
i i'm a afraid to stay with that if
people want me to
just we have a lot of questions here uh
about uh ferguson
and uh you know your opinion of the uh
uh
situation there uh uh
ferguson uh ferguson yes
well i don't think there's any doubt
that
on a nationwide basis
there's a preponderance of white
local police officers
to the
exclusion of an equal percentage of
black
or african american officers
that almost inherently
assures that
there'd be a distrust in the
african-american community of the equity
of fairness of the police
uh in
ferguson area
i think they were like a hundred to
three or something like that i don't
remember the exact figures
and that uh crime
which is not
unique as you know since the ferguson
incident took place there had been a
series of reports of similar cases
taking place so i think one
twelve-year-old kid with a
toy pistol was shot by a white policeman
and so forth so so this is a problem
that exists
all over the country and i hope that
what president obama said yesterday
will will eventually prevail
he has some practical approaches that i
think might help at least and it is for
police to be required to wear a camera
to record an incident when this
death might occur to a black person or a
white person and also to
reduce the dependence of local police
forces on
used war materiel that is tanks and
personnel carriers and heavy armor and
things of that kind which i think
creates a very bad psychological
reaction among the black citizens within
a community so i think to let this be
publicized in the ferguson area uh it's
going to have a
nationwide beneficial effect
if it is corrected
well tesla
yes
president we have a number of questions
on iran
where
some students ask you
either to reflect
on what happened at the beginning of the
revolution in iran
but more importantly others are asking
you what is the right course of action
they ask are really sanctions the way to
go what is going to happen i mean i
think our students are very concerned
about the situation in iran
i don't think any students would
remember
the time when i was in the white house
and i had
i had a group of
diplomats
taken prisoner by the iranians
and a lot of people forget that those
were diplomats that i had
approved to go to the revolutionary
government of the ayatollah homaini
after the show was overthrown i
immediately
felt that it was right for us to
establish full diplomatic relationships
with iran
so that we could deal with them in a
equal
and mutually respectful and productive
basis and it was those diplomats that
were taken by some students and then the
ayatollah mania approved they're taking
and they stayed there for more than a
year
which brings us down
to the other part of your question today
as you all
probably know iran is a signatory
of an of a non-proliferation treaty
every country in the world signs this
treaty and agrees to abide by it
uh
turkey except uh
uh
palestine let's say
except uh india and
and uh
israel well israel doesn't know and uh
anyway in pakistan pakistan uh india
pakistan
israel and now of course the north korea
which is withdrawn
so
so iran does comply with the
uh non-proliferation treaty
the united states and israel
particularly and others as well believe
that iran is developing a nuclear weapon
which is not permissible permissive
under the uh
under the nonproliferation treaty
but iran denies it and now the
negotiation is whether or not
we should continue our very severe
economic sanctions on iran to force them
to comply with the demands of the rest
of the world
and as you know we have not been able to
reach an agreement with iran and just
recently we've now extended the time for
i think for another six months during
which time we'll continue to negotiate
iran claims that all of the highly
explosive material that they are
developing are enriched uranium and some
plutonium are being developed just for
peaceful purposes so the question is are
they telling the truth or not
but i believe that the best way to
resolve this is for us to have as much
full
cooperation and communication
and negotiation with iran as possible to
stay aloof from a problem of that
kind is counterproductive and as you
know the elders of which you and i are
two of the ten members or so uh the
elders do go to iran on occasion we're
looking for an excuse to go back to iran
again so i think it's very good for us
to have maximum communication with iran
to this
insist that they do not develop
uh highly explosive material
and to make sure they agree to let the
international atomic energy
inspectors come in and inspect them so
communicate
but be insistent that you don't develop
a nuclear weapon
i think we have time for one more
question and uh
this is a question from a uh yell
freshman actually
uh says thinking back on camp david and
the camp david accords yes
uh what did we learn
from that situation that might be
applicable to the situation with israel
and palestine today
well i would say that my number one goal
in life
politically speaking since
for the last 35 years has been to bring
peace to israel
and the only way you can do that is to
have peace with israel and its immediate
neighbors now the palestinians
informally when i became president it
was egypt
egypt and israel had been to war four
times in the 25 years before i became
president so i said that as a high goal
for myself and eventually a recent
agreement with the prime minister of
israel and the president of egypt for
peace treaty
and that peace treaty has now been in
effect more than 35 years not a single
word of it has been violated because the
peace treaty was carefully devised by me
and them
to be beneficial to both sides so no
matter who is the leadership
in the leadership position in israel or
egypt they are not going to abandon that
treaty because it's still very valuable
to them another lesson that i've learned
is it's not not any way
to make recalcitrant
parties like israel and the palestinian
to agree anything unless the president
of the united states is directly and
personally and forcefully involved
i know that john kerry has done a
wonderful job in trying to bring about
some progress there
but at this point it seems to me that
the situation is getting worse and worse
every day
we know that it's violence now
in israel there's an altercation about
the most holy site of the of the
israelis of the jews and and their
muslims and the israeli government is
now considering very seriously
uh to change their laws so that it's
identifiable as only a jewish state
whereas about 20 percent of the total
citizens are
non-jews or muslims
i just read on the news just before i
came here i turned on my ipad
and uh
prime minister netanyahu has called for
new elections
because he's tired of the moderate
i say this moderate israelis
criticizing his more conservative
government so he's called for a new
election so he can choose a more
conservative government which i think is
a step in the right direction there's an
outsider looking in but i prayed always
every night as a matter of fact that
israel can find peace with its neighbors
because i know that there's bloodshed on
both sides and horrible hatred is
increasing every day it's something
that's worthy of direct
forceful involvement by the united
states and i think neither the
palestinians nor israel are in a
position to reject
a strong move by the president of the
united states if he decides to do so
so uh president zedillo just handed me
one last set of questions
set up questions
but they're they're essentially on the
same theme okay
and they're personal
these are students asking essentially
what is it in your life
spiritual intellectual
other
that has allowed you
to become
the great global citizen that you are
the great public servant that you are
uh uh the uh
uh and and and and how
they want to draw inspiration from this
so
uh not to put you on the spot but uh
what do you what do you see as uh the
formative uh experience for you in your
life without agreeing to the premises of
your
fairness
well you know i grew up as i said in a
in a
deprived neighborhood
nobody in my father's family had been
further than 10th grade in high school
and
my daddy wanted me to go to
college it was during the great
depression years and there were only two
three colleges in america then
annapolis and west point
and i decided to go to annapolis because
of reasons i need not describe now but i
i did and i i was lucky enough
to graduate from annapolis and was a
successful naval officer then i went
back home
to plains and i began to see
this was in 1953 i began to see the
horrible
blight of racial segregation on our
black neighbors
who were still my friends and on the
white people as well
and so i became the chairman of it
of a sumpter county
education board of school board
and i decided to run for the state
senate i never had any interest in
politics before but
the public school system was threatened
to be shut down if a black student
entered the classroom then so i went to
the state senate and i began to see that
i had
opportunities and talents
to be utilized and i remember what my
high school
superintendent said she was miss julia
coleman and i quoted her by the way
in my presidential inaugural speech and
also when i got the nobel peace prize
mrs studio coleman said we must
accommodate changing times
but cling to unchanging principles
and in a fast-changing technical world
there are new ideas and new challenges
and new opportunities
and and new
new
problems that come up but there are
certain principles
that never change and i say they're
basically expressed in our great
religions and in other moral values the
most
clear secular expression
of the highest ideals of human beings
was the universal declaration of human
rights in 1948
i believe and
that expresses
the the highest
patterns that we can set for ourselves
or
anyone under us and i've tried to live
by that
but i'm i i'm still
basically inherently a peanut farmer
from georgia and i and i've had
wonderful opportunities so i've tried to
take advantage of some of those
opportunities and when i do try
something new uh it's not because i feel
a duty to do it it's because i enjoy it
you know it's it's something that's
that's different and
exciting and un
unpredictable and challenging and
adventurous and ultimately gratifying
and one of the main things i've learned
i'm trying to put a lot in one in one
brief answer
the main thing i've learned is when we
go to poor people
uh to eliminate a disease
or to build a home but they never had a
house before we work side by side with
these people
and quite often i go there with the
sense that uh
that they are somehow inferior because
they haven't provided their family with
food or for clothing or education or
health care or home and i find out when
i get to know them
that they're just as intelligent as i am
and just as
hard working as i am
and just as ambitious as i am and their
families are just as good as mine
so i think that
awareness of the equality of
of uh human human beings with each other
in not only a practical way but in the
eyes of god
is one of the most important lessons
i've learned
president carter thank you today for
your bold words your challenging words
and your inspiring words thank you all
for being here thank you
thank you
you all very much
you